ein bisschen aufgeregt ist natascha
milanovic schon
sie ist eine von neun und 20
auszubildenden die heute neu anfangen
als erstes bekommen sie ihre
arbeitskleidung viel zu groß
elektroniker und fachinformatiker wollen
sie mal werden sie ist die einzige frau
in der großen männer die 34-jährige hat
davor als bürokauffrau gearbeitet dann
wurde jeder job zu langweilig als
quereinsteigerin hat sie im handwerk
heutzutage gute chancen
ich habe mich beworben gehabt ich habe
auch ein praktikum gemacht ist und wir
alle lehrlinge kann sie auch eine
besondere prämie hoffen
das kleine ding ist ein auto für den
auszubildenden mit dem besten
notendurchschnitt einmal pro jahr wird
er vergeben und damit der azubi des
jahres gekürt das kurze energie und
gebäudetechnik elektroniker ein ansporn
für die neuen zwölf monate autofahren
ohne für benzin zurückzahlen
die firma musste sich was einfallen
lassen sie sucht händeringend lehrlinge
mit solchen bonbons kann der chef sie
anlocken der wert der auszubildenden
scheint gestiegen zu sein
wenn man direkt in die schulen geht
merkt man das und das ist auch so dass
wir hier natürlich im großraum stuttgart
in einem ballungszentrum sind wohl jeder
auszubildende braucht jedes
industrieunternehmen und da müssen wir
als handwerksbetrieb natürlich auch
schauen dass wir uns entsprechend auch
hier behaupten das unternehmen fertigt
elektrotechnik für den hausbau außerdem
stromtankstellen für elektroautos
es ist sein spezialgebiet ismael iiasa
ist im vierten ausbildungsjahr und
leidet andere lehrlinge schon an nach
sogenannten strom fahrplänen bauen sie
zapfsäulen müssen sich mit elektronik
und mechanik auskennen eine
herausforderung
ich denke schon dass es zu großen firma
sehr sehr wichtig ist die ganze arbeit
was wir da machen also die azubis geben
wirklich hirn damit dass arbeit komplett
läuft was ohne abzüge slagter gar nichts
auch im spanischen restaurant tauro in
berlin hat man das erkannt
dem bischof wii hat hier vor drei wochen
seine ausbildung begonnen
der 19-jährige will restaurantfachmann
werden das heißt kellnern bis in die
nacht und am wochenende arbeiten
darauf haben nur wenige lust
wenn man hergekommen dabei darauf
gestorben
tage später direktiven unterschrieben
ich war schon er ist einer von 30 neuen
auszubildenden die hälfte davon sind
köche vergangenes jahr sah das ganz
anders aus
kein einziger lehrling hatte sich
geworden der staat musste reagieren
nun hat er die ausbildungs gehälter
verdoppelt auf 950 euro monatlich jetzt
mal was neues mit speck fängt man mäuse
wir werden unsere ausbildungsvergütung
im blick auf mindestlohn auf die
veränderungen die auch bundesweit an
stehen ab ersten januar 2015 werden wir
dann den azubis mehr geld geben ganz so
viel verdienen die lehrlinge beim
elektrobetrieb heldinnen nicht aber mit
700 euro monatlich kommt natascha
milanovic klar
sie weiß nach der ausbildung wird man
sie heiß umworben wird voller stimmt
heutzutage suchen die firmen ja die
azubi sogar schon und versuchen mit
angeboten zu locken
ich bin zumindest froh dass ich auf
jeden fall eine ausbildung hat ja schon
jedes jahr bildet der betrieb rund 30
neue auszubildende aus vielleicht wird
ein kleines auto als prämie bald nicht
mehr reichen